if you
Good morning church. My name is TR Lewis like John said
and it's a pleasure to get to be with you
this morning opening God's word and worshiping so thank you to Joe and
the worship team for leading us this this
month through the month of July. Henderson Hills has been blessed
to have over 100 Years of cumulative preaching
experience in the pulpit.
And this is my second time. So we'll bring the average
down a little bit today.
But but praise God that he uses Broken Vessels.
To preach his word. We pray that the spirit this morning would open our
hearts. So let's do that this morning in prayer.
Father God as we come to your word.
May we do it humbly.
May we let your word do the work?
Of conviction, maybe we
let your spirit.
Do the work.
of opening
our eyes and our hearts to your truth.
Jesus name we pray amen.
Amen, well my family and I've been here for about 18 years
at Henderson Hills, and we've loved
Henderson Hills and you guys have loved us very well over this
time.
And about a year in about a year into our time here at Henderson Hills
Mike wall.
Invited me to go on a medical mission trip
to Indonesia to do a medical relief trip
after the the devastating tsunami to hit
in 2004 and and I
was humbled when he asked me to do that and when
I say humbled, I mean really proud that he asked
me to do that. There's a little
bit of a mix and I I pray those in my medical training. I
was in my residency at that time and I'd pray that God would start to open that door
for medical missions. I've done some of that earlier in
life, but was really eager to do more.
And about a week before we were supposed to leave on that
trip. I was at work at the
hospital on a call shift.
And I had experienced a pain
in my chest that I had not known before to
that degree.
See for years.
For years before this. I've been having these little pains in
my chest that would that would get me down. It was
usually after a long bike ride or a workout and I've
had it checked out when I was in high school never really
got an answer as to what it was.
But in that moment on that day that pain took me to my
knees and I could I couldn't breathe well, and I
had to had to seek help.
And the doctor years before had said if you're
in the middle of one of these episodes go find and get
a chest x-ray.
And so as I found myself in the
ER it was easy. So I I got a
chest x-ray that day. I hadn't for years for a decade. I'd ignored
that.
And when that x-ray got developed it showed that my left lung
was 30% collapsed and so it explained it was
the answer to what had been plaguing me all those years.
It was the answer that required a treatment.
So I wrestled in that I had that week of man. I
really want to go and all my doctors that were training me said you
can't you can't go forward with this. You have to get it fixed.
And so I sat in Mike's office with tears and
told him that I wasn't going to be able to go but I had to submit.
To having that problem surgically treated and so I did.
See I was I was used to being the one diagnosing the problem.
I was used. I was in training to fix the problem I had
on I was the one in the scrubs and the white coat. I wasn't supposed to
be the one having the surgery.
But I did and the Lord used that time in a
really really special way.
You see I was broken physically in that time and it revealed
a need for help.
The X-ray gave the diagnosis, but the X-ray
didn't make my lung collapsed. They merely
gave the answer.
It and I'd use that line. I'd use that phrase with
patience that that this MRI this didn't give
you whatever your problem is, but now it is a step towards
fixing it.
But for me, that was a little bit hard to hear myself.
So today we look at God's word. Look at his Passage.
And we want to see our hearts the way
God sees them.
We want to see them for how they really are.
So today just to put everybody kind of
at ease a little bit. We're going to answer we're gonna fill in all the blanks on
your notes first.
So our theme is seen seeing God's heart the way he
does.
The next line on there is God sees our sin.
He sees our sin.
The second one is God knows our heart.
He can see our hearts and he knows
our hearts.
The third line in your notes is God has made a
way to make us clean.
He sees our sin our sin separates us from him and he has
made a way to make us clean.
The fourth line is he is just and
he is just a fire.
He is just and he is just a fire and in him. We are
Justified.
In him, we are Justified.
So we got out of the way so I don't have to worry about touching all those points and you guys
can listen. You've got your notes filled out.
So you can sit back and relax and
enjoy.
But this morning we're going to turn in your turn your Bibles to Luke chapter
18, we're gonna be studying verses 9 through
14. And as we read Jesus's words, he's speaking
to a very prideful bunch.
And so as we read these words if you catch yourself thinking I know
who really needs to hear this.
I've got this golf buddy or a Facebook friend or my
kids or my spouse.
If you're thinking that beware.
If you get through this passage, you have a list of who you're going to send the link
to afterwards.
Let's think again.
So let's come to the passage.
Luke chapter 18 verses 9 through 14 he told this Parable
to some who trusted in themselves that they
were righteous and treated others with
contempt.
So he told this story.
Two men went up into the temple to pray one a
Pharisee and the other tax collector.
the Pharisee standing by himself prayed thus
God I thank you that I'm not like the other men.
Extortioners unjust adulterers or
even like this tax collector. I fast
twice a week. I give tithes of
all that I get.
But the tax collector standing far off would not even lift up his
eyes to heaven.
He beat his breast.
Saying God be merciful to me a sinner.
I tell you this man went down to
his house Justified rather than the other for everyone
who exalts himself will be humbled. But the one who humbles
himself will be exalted.
this reading this morning the story that
Jesus tells is one of self-righteousness on
the part of the Pharisee resulting in Pride and his
looking on others is truly an example of not seen
our own Hearts the way that God does.
So let's take a few minutes to kind of walk through this story. We're
going to look at some of the details better and see how we
can take away from this story and how it can affect our
lives.
And really this is a story within a story right this the
grander story is Luke telling his
holy and spirit Holy Spirit inspired.
count of Jesus's life
and in the middle of this the middle of Jesus on the
road traveling meeting people and teaching we have this story of
two guys walk into a temple, right?
And so for the for the previous nine chapters of
Luke Jesus has been in this midst of
a journey towards Jerusalem. He's progressing towards Jerusalem
and we see glimpses of his teaching glimpses of
his interactions with the Pharisees and tax collectors
all along the way.
And so he's he's journeying towards you somewhere at this
point between Galilee and Jericho.
And all along he's teaching he's healing he's being
challenged.
He's really he's just one chapter ways towards the end. He's just
one chapter away from riding into Jerusalem on the Donkey.
And so this isn't the first time he's been challenged by
the Pharisees. This isn't his first message. In fact
two chapters earlier. If you look at if you look back just flip a page back probably
to Luke 16
He gives a very clear word to the Pharisees in Luke chapter 16
verse 15.
They just challenged him about his teaching. He says you were
those who justify yourself before men.
But God knows your heart.
For what is exalted among men is an abomination in the
side of God.
But apparently that didn't do the trick that that didn't
resonate with them in some way and so he goes on he teaches
his disciples more in this
first part of chapter 18 about prayer and then he
moves on to the story.
These two guys walk into a temple.
But of course, they're not any two guys.
It's a Pharisee and a tax collector.
And so
although we see the Pharisees as bad guys and the
tax collectors is the perennial hero of the story.
That's not how they would have viewed that that's not how the dusty people
sitting around. Jesus's feet would have heard
this story at first.
I seen the Pharisees were actually the religious Elite of
the day.
They were the ones who put forward the facade of righteousness. They
were the ones who upheld Jewish teaching and
law and even exceeded it in the way that they lived.
They prided themselves in being righteous examples and going beyond
the law.
And the tax collectors they were the they were the most demised.
So let's look a little bit so the tax collectors.
Reserve they regarded himself as these Pious preservers
of the law.
And is interesting they didn't have this wasn't like a bestowed title. This
was someone who chose.
To walk this extra Road they added on
to God's law.
They had no official power, but they put forward this
extra holiness.
In an attempt to Garner a respect
among the people, right? Certainly all
the Pharisees had fish stickers on the backs of their cars,
right?
And this week we were talking with some friends
of my life reminded me early in our relationship and our
dating relationship. I gave her a fish placard the nice silver one
to go in the back of her car.
And I assured her in that moment that if she had the fish placard
on the back of her car then she would be safe from
ever getting pulled over having a ticket.
This is not a story only made for the pull but this is a real story.
That night driving home from her house. I got pulled over.
With a fish placard on the back of my car and went
away from there with not one but two tickets for my
infractions at night.
But it wouldn't have been uncommon to see the Pharisees in the temple.
It wasn't unusual for Pharisees to come into the temple.
And actually they had they would go they had their regular seats even right
and they would assume those.
But Jesus wasn't fooled.
He could see their hearts and if you look back at Matthew 23 later
this week, you'll see how Jesus really felt about the Pharisees
and the scribes.
So what about the tax collector?
A tax collectors were the black hat Cowboys. They were the bad
guys.
Right, they would have seldom be seen darkening the doorsteps
of the Temple.
most of them were Jewish
a lot of them like we think Matthew had something happen earlier
in his life. Mostly had something where they went away. They turned away
from their Jewish Heritage. They turned away from their
faith and they became sellouts to the Romans.
They were collecting taxes to the for the Romans from their Hebrew
Brethren, but they were also extortioners right
they were robbing. They were cheating.
their brothers
he was it wasn't natural for them to continue to associate
they were considered separated but in
a bad way.
So we have to put aside kind of our VBS lenses where
we know the Pharisees a bad guy. We know the tax collector or
something good is going to happen and we can why we want to watch this
story evolve.
So let's look at their postures as they enter the temple.
It says in Luke and the ESV that both of them came in
they stood right?
But in the Greek those words for stand are very different.
The Greek word for standing used of the Pharisee is
one of assuming his regular
seat, right? He was standing with pride.
He was standing as if he deserved to be there.
in the presence of God
Not necessarily bad, but
it is if you carry that pride in your
heart.
The word stand we see for the tax collector is a
timid attitude. It even says that he was standing far
off. He wasn't even in the same part of the temple. He didn't he
didn't feel himself equal to that.
And he stood with a timid way even a different word used.
And he had his head hung. He wouldn't lift. He
couldn't lift.
His eyes up.
to the Lord
So in this physical expression of their
spiritual conditions, we see these two men come and
do the temple.
But what about their prayers as Jesus unpacks their
prayers we start to really see their heart.
And really the Pharisees prayer isn't as much of a prayer
as it is a self-righteous Soliloquy before
God.
He's laying out all the things that he is not
and he lays out all the reasons that God should
love him.
First he thinks God that he is not like other men. He thanks
God that he's not an extortioner. He's not unjust. He's
not an adulterer.
And he punctuates it by saying I'm not like this other
man this tax collector.
It seems as though he was aware of his surroundings
aware of what was going on and even from a surface
level presentation of
We we see that God reveals. Jesus is revealing. This
Pharisee is prideful.
He's using comparison of himself with others as
a means to.
Cover up the sin. That's really in his
life.
It gives him a self-assurance. It gives himself.
Justification as he makes these comparisons.
But then he moves on he moves on to boast about
his holy actions of the things
that he does.
Above and beyond the law first. He boasts about
his fasting.
Jewish law at that time required that they fast once a
year.
And that on the day of atonement.
In this Pharisee boasts before God that he fasts twice a
week.
To celebrate Moses going to the mountain and coming back
down.
a few days later
and so he
he's boasting this righteous action before God.
He boasts about as fasting.
the exact opposite
of what we're called to do of what Jesus teaches us
to do.
He talks about.
his tithing
he logs his time and he Tides everything that
he gets was common for the Pharisees and that day to tithe
off spices and herbs in every
single thing and it was above and beyond what that Mosaic
law had commanded.
So the the self-inflated practice of the
Pharisees in general particularly this one that we read of today, it
left no room for a need for savior.
their attempts
Filling the law and going beyond the law themselves.
Put everything on their plate.
But these practices were meaningless to God
because he could see their hearts.
And now we see the tax collector the tax collector
standing far off and another part of the temple with his head
hung.
He was ashamed of his sin, but he didn't run from
God.
He came to the temple to pray and to plead with God for
mercy.
And I believe that this is evidence of the work of the holy spirit in his
life.
Even before he entered the temple that day if there
was something that brought him in.
There was something that brought him into that place before God.
He knew that he could go there and receive Mercy. It may
have been a lesson that he learned as a child.
Even before he left and turned
to his his life as a tax collector.
And the prayer the tax collector is one that can serve as a model for
us today.
When we're faced with a Brokenness of sin.
And as much as the Pharisees heart was full of Pride. The tax
collectors was overcome with Brokenness and
humility.
So we read his plea to the Lord. He says
these words God be merciful
to me a sinner.
He got it, right.
With hot tears and a burning throat. He confessed his sinfulness to
the only one who could forgive and wash away
his sins.
And as we read this prayers, we read these words of the
tax collector reminded of Psalm 51.
And Psalm 51 David is praying a
similar prayer.
In the first three verses he says have mercy
on me o God.
According to your steadfast love according to your abundant Mercy
bought out my transgressions.
Wash Me thoroughly from my iniquity and cleanse me
from my sin for I know that my transgressions
And my sin is ever before me.
David had received the diagnosis of his Brokenness and
he went to go be healed from it.
And we see the reality of this working out in
verse 17 later in the chapter.
or David says
the sacrifices of God or a broken
spirit
a broken and contrite heart o God,
you will not despise.
And that's exactly what we see the tax collector bringing before
God a broken spirit.
A broken and contrite Hearts. You
see he doesn't boast in himself.
He asks only for mercy.
So the tax collector saw his sin the way
that God did.
And in these seven words that he prays he impacts the
whole truth of the gospel for us.
He starts out with God. He cries out to God His Holy Father our
Holy Father.
the god of Mercy
he confesses that he is a sinner.
In fact, he confesses that he is the
sinner the way it's phrase. The originally says
I Am The Sinner as if you were the only one
and he is he's only one for God before God.
We see him beat his breast. He's not beating his
hands. He's not beating his mind. He's beating his chest his
heart.
As if he knows where the root of his sin is,
he's attacking that root of sin and
then he pleads for mercy.
I need Mercy.
He seeks Mercy from our merciful god.
And we see a translated as mercy and in other words for the translation of
that in the Greek is propitiate me God be
merciful to me propitiate me.
And that's one of my favorite words that used in the New Testament as
John and Paul used propitiation to describe
Christ atoning sacrifice for us.
And that's a word that we don't we don't throw around much propitiation, but
it means atonement.
It means paying the price that we couldn't pay on
our own right?
It means appeasing a holy God for the penalty of
our sin.
And it's what Christ did for us you see Christ is
the propitiation for our sin and
also our propitiator.
It's a means of regaining favor a propitiation to
regains that favor that was lost in the
garden.
It's Christ's earning back a forgiveness that we couldn't earn
on our own through any tithing or fasting or
anything that we might do.
in first John
in Chapter 2 in chapter 4 there are two verses that John
teaches about this. He says my little children. I'm writing
these things to you that you may not sin.
But if anyone does sin we have an advocate with the father
Jesus Christ the righteous he is a
propitiation.
For our sins and not for
ours only but also for the sins of the
world.
And then he goes on to chapter 4 to say in this love not
that we have loved God, but that he loved us.
And sent his son to be the propitiation for our
sins.
Through that gift. It's through that propitiation that he averts
that Jesus averts the Wrath.
of our holy God
So in this short prayer the tax collector pleads for exactly what
he needs.
It's amazing how at times the Holy Spirit can
work a perfect understanding of this complex.
process
theologians have written volumes and volumes on mercy
and Grace and
salvation and propitiation and total
Reliance on God, but it's the tax collector gets
it he gets propitiation even without
the study
I think about a
high school student who can drain three-pointer after
three pointer, right or hit a
300 yard drive down the Fairway.
It would take professors.
Lecture Halls full of chalkboards to explain the physics and
the mechanics behind what it takes to do those
things and yet naturally people can just
do that in their gifting and that's that's similar to
how the Holy Spirit I think works in this tax collector. He
doesn't understand all the mechanics. He
just understands.
That the god before he
please his merciful.
And that this God sent his son Christ.
To forgive us of our sins and so the tax collector gets
propitiation.
He understands it.
You see we don't have to be theological Giants to come
before the cross.
We just have to be humbled by our sin and see our
hearts the way God sees them.
We have to recognize that separation that our sin.
creates
and then we have to remember that God made a way to make us clean. He
doesn't want us to stay separated. He doesn't want us to stay in our sin. He's
made a way to make us clean and he's made it through the washing
of the blood of Jesus Christ.
And what does the tax collector receive when he finishes his
prayer for mercy?
He went away Justified.
Jesus says that that man went down to his house Justified.
But not the other he makes a clear distinction that the
Pharisee was not justified by any of the things that he boasts
in.
And as we read about this justification, I
want to share a little excerpt. This
is Charles spurge and his commentary about this part of the story and
it was really neat and less you think that I read
a lot of Charles Spurgeon Alan shared this with me so credit to
him.
It says this is this is spurgeon's
words. This is all that Christ did for him was cast
about his shoulders to be the robe of
his Beauty.
That moment all the guilt that he had ever committed himself
was washed entirely away and
lost forever.
when a sinner believes in Christ his sins positively
cease to be
And what is more wonderful they all cease to be?
As Kent says in these well-known lines.
It's a poem.
It says here's pardon for the transgressions past
it matters not how black they're
cast.
And oh my soul with Wonder View.
For sins to come. Here's pardon,
too.
They're all swept away in one solitary instant
the crimes of many years.
extortions adulteries or even
murder
wiped away in an instant
For you will notice the Absolution was instantaneously given.
He went away from that place.
Justified he went away from that place declared.
Holy declared innocent.
by his righteous judge
So let's learn about Justified. Let's learn about being made, right?
as Paul taught the Romans in chapter
Romans chapter 3 verses 21 through 28 28
Paul writes to the Romans he says but now the
righteousness of God has been manifested apart from
the law.
all of the law and the prophets bear witness to
it the righteousness of God through faith
in Jesus Christ for all who believe
amen for there is no distinction for
all have sinned and fall short of the glory of God and
are Justified.
by his grace
as a gift
through the Redemption that is in Christ Jesus.
whom God put forward
as a propitiation by his blood to be
received by faith.
This was to show God's righteousness because in
his Divine forbearance. He had passed over former sins.
It was to show his righteousness that the present time so
that he might be just and justifier of
the one who has faith in Jesus.
Then What Becomes of our boasting?
It is excluded.
By what kind of law by law of Works? No.
by the law of faith
for we hold that one is justified by faith
apart from the works of the law.
See our God is just
and our God is also the justifier.
He sent his son.
to be the propitiation
the blood of Christ shed on our behalf.
We are forgiven.
And the Lord has declared his righteous.
Not through the law but through the blood.
Because on our own we're forsaken.
When we try to do it on our own.
We're without hope.
On our own we have every reason for despair.
We beat our chests and we hang our heads.
but in him
in Christ
We have been Justified. We've been declared righteous. Yes,
he sees our sin. Yes, we beat
our breasts over conviction. We
beat our hearts and repentance and our hatred
of our sin.
And yes, he knows he sees he
hears and yes, he loves us in that.
Yes, he declares this redeemed innocent and
holy.
See Christ defeated our sin.
Through faith and repentance. He declares this. Holy.
Because of Christ and that is how
God sees the hearts of those who come
to him in faith.
He sees our hearts perfectly.
He sees our hearts completely.
We're fully known to him and we're fully loved in
Christ Jesus.
In him we too are Justified
just like the tax collector.
So we see the tax collector go away perfectly
Justified and then Jesus leaves us
with a mic drop paradox.
as he often does
those who exalt themselves will be
humbled.
And the humbled will be exalted.
He punctuates this parable.
with this
Jesus is known for teaching and upside
down life, right?
Lose your life to find it first will be last servant will
be the greatest.
Those who exalt themselves will be humbled.
And those who humble themselves will be exalted but none of this makes sense.
Except in the kingdom of God.
You see we have no need to make much of ourselves before God.
Because anything anything that we might bring is
like filthy rags.
And anything that's good in us as followers
of Christ is because of the work that the Holy Spirit has
done in our lives.
The friends we are Justified and we are exalted as
we trust in Christ. But what do we do with that? So what
do we do that as Brothers and Sisters in Christ who are
Justified?
number one
Don't be proud.
Right. There's a Temptation toward that as we
walk in sanctification.
Satan tries to bring up this temptation
towards Pride that maybe we're doing
a little bit of it.
on our own
so don't be proud.
number two
be honest with ourselves and with God about our
sin.
We need to continue to see our hearts the way God sees
them.
That's how we come to the cross at first and that's how we continue
to walk with Christ.
number three
We continue to plea for mercy and continue to rest upon Christ
as a propitiation for our sins.
We understand that our Salvation was bought by the blood of
Christ.
That there's nothing that we did to deserve it and nothing that
we could do.
We need to remind ourselves that it was done willingly by
God.
Because of his love for us.
Not to appease an Angry God.
But to satisfy the holy Wrath of a
loving God.
What else do we do with our justification?
number four We Trust in it
We Trust in that justification
we see our heart the way God sees it now he sees us
as holy and redeeming so we don't let
the shame of sin continue because we
know that those sins have been forgiven.
and when Satan tries to hold those over our heads
we say no.
We rest in the blood of Christ.
We trust that we forgiven and have been made
clean.
We don't forget from where we've come but we rest that
we've been made clean and then walk in that identity.
We walk out first Thessalonians 5, right we pray continually
we rejoice in all circumstances.
We give thanks.
We walk for his glory.
We walk with thankful hearts and we celebrate we celebrate the
work that God has done in US.
We Rejoice like Paul and Galatians 2 that we've been crucified
with Christ.
And that we no longer live, but Christ lives in US.
so the next question is
but what if I'm a Pharisee?
What if outwardly?
I put forward this facade of righteousness, but inwardly.
I'm broken and sick and deflated.
What if I've tried to build my own righteousness apart from
God?
Well, I think what Jesus tells us is
those who exalt themselves will be humbled.
And that's a good place to be.
I would say if you say what if I'm a Pharisee, I
would say let the overwhelming love of God overtake you.
Let his truth let the word of God cover and
saturate you let it expose the true depth
of your need for him.
Stop ignoring sin.
Stop trying to fix or manage sin on your
own.
Stop playing the comparison game to help you deal with your sin.
Stop simply polishing that empty facade and
devoting yourself to appearances.
If we see ourselves as the Pharisee, we have to let our
walls of perception down.
And let me let you in all on a secret. We all still sin.
Every older every Church staff member every worship leader
every community group leader every student leader.
Every single person in this building and outside of this building.
Still has to deal with sin.
If you're the Pharisee like I at times in
the past have been the Pharisee and want to try to fix it.
don't
beat your breast beat your heart plead to
God for Mercy from Humble and can try
heart and receive justification.
Receive the justification that the tax collector
received.
Don't lament or be scared when your sin is exposed.
But walk into that.
Let the Holy Spirit bring comfort in that
knowing that it's only at that time that you
can come to the cross.
Acknowledge acknowledgment of sin doesn't make it any
more harmful.
In fact, it exposes it and it brings
it to light so that you
so that the holy spirit so that God can start about the work of healing.
So this morning wherever you find yourself on the spiritual Spectrum allow
the Holy Spirit to work.
No doubt. He's already at work. If you're in here today, if you're hearing
these words, he's already at work.
So let your eyes be open to the reality of
sin.
Let your eyes be open to the reality of who Christ.
Has called you to be in him.
Trust in Christ as a propitiation
for our sins as the atonement.
And trust in God as our just justifier.